when you do come in to speak to some of
these Georgia Southern students are
these things that they are aware of or
do they are they thinking of that that
extra money to do traveling or or for
distribution things like that they know
you just want to make the film they just
was sort of like this Rockstar life and
it sounds fun it's whether there's the
thing it doesn't matter if you're a
Georgia Southern student or a UCLA
student or a NYU student no college
student well that's maybe not true most
college students do not think about the
totality of the picture because when
they're in film school or when they're
learning how to tell a story or whatever
it is they're doing
they get taught the mechanics of it they
get taught this is a three-act structure
this is how you compose a frame this is
how you run the camera this is how you
turn the sound on and you learn these
technical things but no one and most
schools do not teach the practical
elements of what it means to be a film
professional and that's a very very
different distinction and that's
something that unfortunately most of our
schools let students learn once they get
out into the real world and it's
something that should be taught in our
film schools before they ever leave
college because if they want to do that
they need to understand how to see their
career as a trajectory not a short-term
thing why do you think that's not taught
I mean that's an excellent point
why do you think that the the technical
aspects Cuse me why do you think that
the non-technical I can't even say this
why do you think that that's not taught
and if you were to start a class in that
vein how would you teach it what would
be part of the curriculum sure well I
think it's not taught because most
people in academia haven't worked in the
real world for a long time there's
nothing wrong with that inherently
because most professors that is their
their life calling and their passion and
that's fine
but it's very hard for you to talk about
making a living when you've made your
living teaching for decades right so if
I were to teach a class about how to
make films and how to make a career
making films outside of college I would
start out with finding things that
a complementary one of the first things
that has happened with the advent of the
Internet and with the advent of all
these new platforms that are emerging at
the beginning people thought they could
make videos and they could edit videos
on their own but something people have
discovered with photography with video
with graphics is that if you're not
experienced and don't know what you're
doing you tend to not do a very good job
so people now are paying money for
people to make videos and tell stories
about their brands about their ideas
about their concepts and give them the
opportunity to hire people to do it
those are great ways I think to start
out as a filmmaker because you may not
be telling the narrative or documentary
story you want to tell but you are
learning how to tell a story and how to
tell it effectively for someone else
which is an excellent way to not only
pay your bills to do the thing that you
got your education in or that you aspire
to be doing as opposed to working at
Starbucks or driving for uber you're
actively making something that is a
story whatever that story is and what
that does is if you save your money you
can run off to go make your short films
and run off to go make your
documentaries because you now have more
experience working with someone so when
you go to make your feature film and
you're answering not only to a producer
or a studio or a financier you're
learning to work with clients as a
filmmaker and then you're able to
understand the entire matrix of the
people that you have to work with
professionally is there a place that a
filmmaker good go to learn these things
I think there isn't a specific place
unfortunately I think it comes in real
life I think that comes with experience
trial and error that in some ways is
something that I guess is a good thing
that's not hot because if you did even
if you were taught how to do all of
those things and while I think some of
those skills would be very helpful for
people to learn the classroom life in
many ways is always the best experience
and so I think that when you figure out
how to do something the wrong way
it makes you appreciate and learn how to
do things better the right way
you